[Musique]
Marie Vastel Michel COG Geneviève
Tellier bonsoir bonsoir
félicitations Marie Vastel vous allez
devenir
nouvelle éditorialiste au devoir mais
vous restez au Devoir et vous passez du
tutorialiste félicitations merci
bonne nouvelle pour nous parce que vous
allez avoir plus de temps pour venir au
panel plus de temps dans la mesure où
vous allez pas être obligé de faire
toujours l'article du lendemain n'est-ce
pas vous allez mais vous allez rester
Ottawa je reste à oui sur la colline
parlementaire mais je compte aller à
Québec en tant que possible
ça c'est fait il y a une heure et demie
à peine suite et fin ça a l'air des élus
je vous montre le résultat du vote de
l'augmentation du salaire de base des
élus québécois 68 pour la CAQ a eu
l'appui des députés libéraux présents je
dis présente il y en a beaucoup qui
était pas là si vous additionnez on est
loin du compte et contre tous les
députés de QS et de du Parti Québécois
ont voté contre alors Michel c'est
on peut montrer le tableau là ils vont
passer ça a l'air de base de 101.000 à
766 pour être très exact c'est une
augmentation de salaire de base de 30 %.
voilà
c'est pas le problème c'est pas
l'augmentation et même c'est la façon
dont ça a été fait ils vont se retrouver
le voilà va se retrouver avec des
négociations avec le secteur public cet
automne où il va être obligé d'expliquer
que des députés méritaient 30%
d'augmentation alors qu'il va offrir
beaucoup moins externe évidemment à ses
employés ça commence mal de conciliation
il ne savait le caucus de la cactinée à
son augmentation
et
[Musique]
c'est prochainement à l'automne on va
recommencer ça ça se traduit dans le
département
Geneviève et Marie les députés québécois
sont compare les autres provinces les
autres législatures et non pas le
Parlement fédéral mais seront les mieux
payés au Canada Geneviève maintenant
ouais mais les salaires sont très
faibles dans les autres provinces alors
je pense que peut-être que standard
devrait effectivement être le
gouvernement fédéral dans beaucoup de
provinces les salaires ont été gelés
pendant des années puis on est partout
frileux pour augmenter justement les
salaires puis on le veut au Québec je
suis d'accord avec Michel le problème
c'est pas tant la l'augmentation quoi
qu'elle est quand même importante de 30
% d'un coup mais c'est la manière dont
ça a été fait en plus on peut pas
s'empêcher de voir un certain cynisme à
cette mesure-là en début de mandat donc
oui la prochaine étape c'est la négo des
salaires des augmentations de salaire
d'un secteur public mais la vraie étape
c'est dans quatre ans dans 4 ans je
pense qu'on va avoir oublié ça puis on
va passer au sujet Marie un petit mot
là-dessus c'est aussi un peu expéditif à
la dernière semaine de la session pas de
débat effectivement ça ça paraît pas
très bien comme on dit et ils sont les
mieux payés des provinces peut-être que
c'est pas assez comme dit Madame Tellier
mais c'est pas ceux qui s'y est
nécessairement il ne ciel pas nécessaire
beaucoup plus que les autres provinces
par exemple à titre de comparaison en
Ontario en siège 24 semaines au Québec
26 semaines en Ontario siège le lundi
aussi cela dit donc le salaire semble
pas mal plus élevé pour à peu près le
travail équivalent ce qui n'aide pas non
plus les perceptions pour le public je
pense vous les voyez là les les
comparatifs Québec désormais c'est
131.000 Alberta 120 etc et la Chambre
des communes on le voit c'est nettement
nettement plus payé avec
194000 salaires de base voilà alors
Monsieur johnstun à qui on a demandé de
partir à qui la Chambre des Communes a
demandé de quitter de ne pas poursuivre
son travail qui n'était plus crédible
était entendu devant un comité il y a
deux grands sujets il y a le pourquoi ne
recommande-t-il pas une enquête publique
je vous fais entendre un premier extrait
un échange avec le député IEN du Bloc
québécois puis on ira à l'autre sujet
après est-il encore crédible mais
d'abord sur l'enquête publique on écoute
la chambre à la majorité nous a dit il
faut faire une commission d'enquête
publique et indépendante et moi quand
j'ai lu le document de Monsieur Johnson
il la rejette cette possibilité là
j'aimerais entendre et savoir pourquoi
il rejette la commission d'enquête
publique indépendante demandée par
autant de gens
donc Marie vous avez tout écouté ça sur
cette sur ça là d'abord on viendra
ensuite à sa crédibilité puis ensuite
encore la légitimité etc mais sur le
fond il n'en démord pas là il dit moi je
pensais je pense toujours ce n'est pas
une bonne idée une enquête publique en
fait au départ il pensait que c'était
une bonne idée le changer d'idée en
consultant les documents et en
constatant dit-il à quel point beaucoup
de ces informations-là ne pourraient pas
être dévoilé publiquement par contre
Monsieur terrien dans d'autres échanges
a vraiment talonné monsieur Johnson à
savoir mais il y a eu des enquêtes sur
des questions de sécurité nationale de
documents secrets du SARS ou de la GRC
et elles ont pu aller de l'avant en
partie à huis clos monsieur gentil n'a
pas vraiment
clarifier pour quelle raison ça ne
serait pas possible dans ce cas-ci et je
pense que c'était un peu là le problème
de son témoignage c'était prévisible
parce que beaucoup de ces informations
là sont secrètes mais monsieur Johnson
n'a pas clarifié plusieurs éléments de
son rapport non plus des questions qui
de en suspens à la lecture de son
premier rapport par exemple monsieur
Johnston dit qu'il y a pas de lien
direct entre la désinformation contre
certains candidats aux deux dernières
élections fédérales il n'a pas expliqué
quelles sont ses preuves qu'est-ce qui
lui permet de dire ça il n'a pas
clarifier en quoi est-ce qu'il est
convaincu que le député and dog qui
siège comme indépendant mais a été élu
libéral en quoi il n'était pas au
courant qu'elle consulat de Chine à
Toronto a essayé de favoriser sa
candidature pour les libéraux une série
de d'éléments comme ça où on n'a pas eu
plus de réponse qui n'aide pas à
convaincre l'opposition de lâcher le
morceau faut dire que l'opposition avant
même que la rencontre débute
ils ont tous dit qu'il n'y avait pas
grand chose que Monsieur Johnson
pourrait dire pour les faire changer
d'avis mais ça s'est confirmé au fil du
témoignage il y a la sortie de la
rencontre pour l'opposition la cause est
entendue Geneviève et d'ailleurs le vote
la semaine dernière mais
qu'avez-vous pensé de son plaidoyer
aujourd'hui monsieur gentil est-ce que
il a marqué des points ou pas non pas
chez les membres dans l'opinion publique
c'est antique ça a été écouté pour son
plaidoyer là
c'est quoi la laisser quand même
certains une certaine liberté dans leur
façon de penser et donc ça démontre un
peu la façon l'attitude de Monsieur le
Johnson vis-à-vis les députés alors on
entend dire j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour la chambre mais en même temps dans
ses propos on ne sent pas se respecter
là et faut pas oublier monsieur Johnson
c'est l'ancien gouverneur général ça
fonctionne en tant que gouvernement
général c'était de conseiller le Premier
ministre de pas te conseiller les
parlementaires c'était pas d'appuyer les
parlementaires et on sent que cette
relation là est encore là donc il est au
service du Premier ministre mais c'est
pas ça qu'il faut en ce moment puis je
pense qu'il réalise pas
c'est Johnson a fait une vente à faire
aujourd'hui devant que c'était lui la
personne la mieux placée pour continuer
cette enquête là qu'on devait lui faire
confiance avec ce dossier là
mais il y a rien eu de nouveau
disait des extraits de son rapport il
est pas allé plus loin que ce qu'il y
avait déjà dit et souvent plusieurs fois
alors ça n'a pas pu fonctionner et à un
moment donné
on a vu monsieur terrier tout à l'heure
qui a été un des bons parlementaires qui
l'a questionné mais je sais aussi a été
très bon en disant écoutez là moi je
suis allé le lire le rapport
la partie secrète de votre rapport j'ai
passé inventé Charline à lire c'est
toujours en désaccord avec vous on doit
avoir une enquête publique expliquez-moi
pourquoi il y en faut pas
tout le temps là
un moment donné les gens pourquoi on a
tenu se faire là si il était pour
répéter et répéter répéter toujours la
même chose en fait si je peux me
permettre une le problème c'est que
Monsieur Johnston dit ne me croyez pas
seulement moi sur parole j'ai invité un
comité de parlementaire un office de
surveillance de la sécurité nationale et
les chefs d'opposition à lire mon
rapport confidentiel en fait monsieur
single pas encore fait il attend d'avoir
sa cote de sécurité secrète le problème
c'est que ça ça pourrait prendre des
semaines voire des mois dans le cas de
Monsieur signe pour obtenir sa cote de
sécurité secrète et pendant ce temps-là
il y a personne qui vient
colorer ou endosser les conclusions
monsieur Johnston et on reste un peu
dans cette espèce de de néant et la
population parce que c'est ultimement
elle qui doute de notre processus
électoral elle n'est pas rassurée
et à ça il répond très bien mais une
commission d'enquête vous ne pourriez
pas obtenir les renseignements que moi
j'ai obtenu ou qu'on offre au chef
d'opposition parce que ça on pourrait
pas les rendre public parce que des
secrets alors là on tourne un petit peu
en rond mais ce qui pèse peut-être plus
lourd
c'est ce doute autour de son
intégrité mais est-il trop près du Parti
libéral est-ce que l'avocate qui le
conseillait pour dire qu'il était ou non
en conflit d'intérêt elle-même donnée
aux particules bon c'est dans de l'eau
ce matin aux yeux de l'opposition en
tout cas c'est clair qu'il n'est pas
l'homme de la situation on écoute un
deuxième échange avec Monsieur Bertol
cette fois-ci
vous croyez sincèrement monsieur
Johnston que dans tout ça il y a rien
qui sont qui peuvent donner l'impression
qu'un conflit d'intérêt et vous croyez
que les Canadiens canadiennes doivent
vous croire uniquement sur votre parole
alors il n'y a pas de conflit d'intérêt
il y a pas de fait qui sous-tendent ces
conflits d'intérêt dit-il répétitives
Michel c'est Auger là-dessus est-ce que
il y a eu un mouvement
il faut le dire c'est les conservateurs
qui sont calés sur cette question-là
revenant encore sur la Fondation Périto
revenant sur
l'ami de ski de du Premier ministre
alors que Johnson a répété
un petit garçon là mais mais on n'a pas
appris d'autres choses et on a on a et
les conservateurs on est passé beaucoup
de temps encore une fois essayer de
mettre l'intégrité monsieur Johnson en
cause mais un moment donné ces réponses
sont ses réponses on les savait qu'on a
perdu énormément de temps faire des
redites et non pas sur le fond se marie
que vous avez pensé
ouais je suis d'accord et je suis pas
certaine que ça résonne auprès de la
population d'ailleurs on sent un peu que
les parties d'oppositions ont envie de
parler d'autre chose à la Chambre des
communes en tout cas la période des
questions mais qui se sont un peu
enlisée un même dans ce dossier là et
qui savent pas trop comment changer de
sujet sans avoir l'air de reculer mais
sur cette concept cet apparence de
conflit d'intérêt
monsieur Jansen aïste se défendre en
disant écouté au fil de ma carrière j'ai
eu différents rôles qui font que j'ai
côtoyé différentes personnes
conservateurs ou libéraux mais de dire
que je fais partie d'une clé libérale
c'est faux c'est peut-être vrai mais je
pense que ça rassure grand monde et je
me demande aussi si ça complique pas la
tâche si jamais on en met quelqu'un
d'autre qui est-ce qui serait assez
indépendant qui n'a jamais côtoyé de
premiers jamais côtoyé de libéraux
jamais contre la Fondation Trudeau ça
commence à être compliqué de satisfaire
tout le monde
oui Geneviève
depuis des semaines sans essayer de nous
amener d'autres éléments pour nous
convaincre effectivement il y aura
peut-être pas personne d'autre qui
pourrait faire le travail comme lui ou
que oui il y a pas vu monsieur Trudeau
je pense que pendant 40 ans et une
période où on se voyait pas je l'ai vu
parce que j'étais arrivé dehors et bon
c'est sûr mais c'est très mal défendu et
puis je me pose la question ben avoir
engagé une firme de relations publiques
pour arriver à ce genre de témoignages
là peu convaincant encore une fois ça
démontre peut-être que je me suis Lanton
n'est pas vraiment au fait des
véritables enjeux l'enjeu c'est sa
crédibilité c'est pourquoi il veut
rester en poste ce qui croit qu'il est
la seule personne à pouvoir faire le
travail c'est un peu cette impression là
qu'on ressent en écoutant aujourd'hui et
donc un exercice de relations publiques
à nous faire il doit comprendre qu'il
est dans une autre politique c'est plus
comme avant lorsqu'il était gouverneur
général je pense qu'il y a pas très bien
saisi les enjeux auxquels il est
confronté
et lui reste debout là il dit savez-vous
j'ai eu un mandat du Premier ministre je
vais finir il y a comme quelque chose
hors du temps quand même que qu'il faut
souligner je vous fais entendre un
échange à Monsieur Poirier monsieur
Trudeau là-dessus qu'on vient tout de
suite
est-ce qu'on peut finalement mettre fin
à cette farce monsieur le Président et
déclenché une vraie enquête publique
pendant que le chef du Parti
conservateur continue ses attaques non
fondées contre l'ancien gouverneur
général et son équipe il prétend vouloir
connaître les vraies réponses il n'a
simplement qu'à accepter le briefing
confidentiel est top secret qui lui est
offert par nos agences de sécurité
alors voilà c'est fait aujourd'hui à
partir de maintenant qu'arrive-t-il tour
de table là-dessus Marie c'est une bonne
question je pense que ça tourne en rond
j'ai pas l'impression que l'un ou
l'autre des deux camps veut reculer et
bien franchement je pense que en
diffusant à communiquer de presse une
lettre ouverte qui l'a envoyé à tous les
membres de la tribune de la presse à
atawa Monsieur Johnston un peu lié les
mains aussi du Premier ministre Trudeau
en disant je ne reste pas mon mandat
vient du gouvernement et j'ai encore du
travail à faire comme disait madame
Tellier il visiblement monsieur Johnson
pense qu'il est le mieux placé pour
régler la question étudier la question
en envoyant ce communiqué là il a aussi
un peu enlever des options à Monsieur
Trudeau donc même si Monsieur Trudeau
avait envie de le remercier
ça serait un peu mal vu donc
peut-être que le tout se calmera cet été
j'ai des doutes par exemple parce que
les fuites continuent dans les médias
très bien Michel c'est
on est dans un cul-de-saclan la Chambre
des communes à majorité a dit on a plus
confiance en vous et le principal
intéressé de toute façon je pense
souvent de vous alors je n'ai rien la
Syrie de vote de la Chambre des communes
il y a rien qui va avancer la question
c'est est-ce que Monsieur Johnson encore
à quelle divinité auprès du public ça je
pense que à chaque fois qu'il fait un
exercice comme celui qui a fait
aujourd'hui il a un père encore un autre
doux auprès du public Geneviève
la prochaine étape c'est ces enquêtes
c'est des audiences publiques alors
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui vont se
pointer en juillet on peut contraindre
les gens mais oui juillet alors
est-ce que les gens vont écouter je ne
pense pas alors qu'est-ce qui va arriver
avec son rapport qui va se pointer j'ai
l'impression qu'il y aura beaucoup de
fonctionnaires mais pas nécessairement
beaucoup de gens du public donc ça aussi
mais je pense que Monsieur gentil lui va
continuer un rapport à remettre au mois
de novembre décembre mais oui je pense
que les fluides vont continuer et puis
les attaques de l'opposition vont
continuer très certainement Marie Michel
Geneviève merci beaucoup bonne soirée et
à très bientôt au revoir